nein was kommt jetzt meine lebensfreude
da ist die letzte mal so mega super ich
ankam gar nicht mehr gedacht mache ich
weiter meine wir haben eine tolle
mit luca
[Musik]
das war ein unfall keine ahnung was
daran lustig sein soll
aber für mich gibt es die kerze
ausgegangen ja das ist auch eher
trauriger ist es lustig ist
[Musik]
jeder ist jesus an karneval oder
irgendwie so wahrscheinlich
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
bei solchen videos denken wir irgendwie
immer irgendwelche menschen vor 1000
jahren haben sie bestimmt gedacht wo
1000 jahren haben wir fliegende kutschen
erste liebe war
[Musik]
die schule also meine freundin jule hat
mir wieder die clips rausgesucht wurde
sich dachte da wird luke auf jeden fall
darüber lachen können wir das thüringer
klößen kommen hätte ich auch nicht
gedacht also okay bei dem clip habe ich
verloren
ja ich feiere vögel
online was kommt jetzt wenn es eine
sache gibt die mich täglich zum lachen
bringt dann sind es vögelt und golden
retriever videos und pinguinen definitiv
an schildkröten höheren offiziell autos
mit dazu
er verfällt wieder an gegen vogel video
denn auch schon
[Musik]
ach du camille abily sonst die ruhe
selbst ist mit euch gefällt haben wo
findest du diese kacke juli
warum
warum und wenn man sich noch ein bier
gegeben wurden in der bahn und hat sich
ganz okay nein das ist doch ein wort und
ich habe es auch video
hat wahrscheinlich gar nicht wehgetan am
bauch kommen wir nun allerdings auch
schon zum letzten video das mich julie
heute vorbereitet hat also ich würde
sagen
mal schauen ob ich jetzt hier zum ende
noch mal lachen muss mein gott oh mein
gott habe ich mich nur erschreckt
anstatt dass ich gelacht habe an der
stelle mich dass heute ich bin jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese nicht lachen
challenge gefallen hat würde ich mich
sehr sehr toll war einen daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video hier freunde
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare was
ich in den nächsten nicht lachen
challenge machen soll soll ich auch eine
compilation mal wieder reagieren also
live auf dem video oder soll damit
wieder clips raussuchen abonniert zudem
auch gern einen kanal hier unter dem
video ist kostenlos und verpasst keine
videos mehr und wenn ihr schon aber da
ist ja dann klicken auf die glocke dann
bekommt er eine benachrichtigung sobald
ein neues video online geht und jetzt
meine damen und herren kommt
als erstes vor allem 150 wieder so junge
beste leben
[Musik]
o